My kids are up like roosters at 5 AM, and it's driving my husband and I crazy.
So, we're getting some advice from Dr. Marc Weissbluth.
When children are sleep-deprived,...
...they have more difficulty self soothing themselves back to sleep,...
...so they tend to start the day too early.
Dr. Weissbluth is a kids' sleep expert,....
...who has spent weeks helping us set sleep rules and start a bedtime routine.
And they have worked, as you can see from an earlier video we made.
Leo, why did you get this present?
I slept last night by myself.
But now, we really need the kids to sleep longer in the morning.
Are we putting the kids to bed too early the night before?
Just how much sleep does a little boy need?
There are published guidelines, but the range is wide.
The best answer to that is to look at his behavior around 4 or 5 PM.
In the afternoon, my kids are cranky.
But, isn't that normal?
He's in an awful mood, and he's cranky because he's short on sleep.
When you're short on sleep, when I'm short on sleep,...
...we become a little bit hypersensitive.
What's happened is, if you look at surveys of bedtimes over decades,...
…ten, twenty, thirty years, it's gotten later and later.
Children are having more difficulty falling asleep or staying asleep or both,...
...in part, because the bedtime is too late.